bonjour la voie libre tous les samedis
sur france 3 est aujourd'hui nous
faisons une infidélité au monde
politique pour nous pencher sur un
secteur primordial dans la vie
bourguignonne le monde du vin à
l'occasion de la fameuse saint vincent
tournante qui se déroule tout ce week
end à gillet sitôt et à vougeot sur ce
plateau avec nous claude chevalier le
président du bvb le bureau
interprofessionnel des vins de bourgogne
pour faire simple pour les néophytes
pour présenter tout le monde viticole
bourguignon bonjour à vous bonjour
thierry gaudillère directeur de la revue
bourgogne aujourd'hui la bible des
amateurs des vins de bourgogne bonjour
thierry bonjour et guillaume
d'angerville président délégué de
l'association des climats de bourgogne
je fais court parce que la réalité de
l'association c'est l'inscription des
climats de bourgogne au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
est ce l un des gros dossier de l'année
bonjour guillaume humbert ville avant
d'ouvrir ce dossier des climats parce
qu'on va en parler longuement on va
revenir d'abord sur novembre dernier son
chevalier au moment de la vente des vins
des hospices de beaune on sait que les
cours cette vente de charité sont en
partie vu comme un baromètre des prix en
général et vous avez poussé on va se
dire un coup de gueule contre une
nouvelle hausse des prix à la vente des
hospices est ce que c'était une hausse
de trop c'est à dire que la réalité
c'est mon coup de gueule était plutôt
sûr phénomène d'organisation de la vente
des vins moi je peux être un
traditionaliste considère que la vente
des vins est l'événement majeur
médiatique bourguignon et ils doivent
conserver un certain système qui
respecte tout le monde et j'ai un peu
attaquées christine pas seulement sur le
fait de l'augmentation des prix il est
vrai que le le système tel qu'il est
fait aujourd'hui fait que les premiers
acheteurs sont souvent des particuliers
qui vont acheter une pièce de 20 et qui
finalement donne un peu le ton
maintenant est-ce que c'est négatif ou
pas je n'en sais rien on a toujours
considéré en bourgogne que la vente des
vins et même si par certains était
considéré comme un baromètre n'en est
pas un c'est pas parce que les prix
augmentent à la vente des vins qui priva
augmenter ou à la propriété ou
transaction négoce mais y avait un
contexte derrière saad augmentation
régulière depuis plusieurs années avec
des années toute petite récolte donc de
gens qui se disent elle je vais
peut-être augmenter parce que sinon
j'aurais moi
une rentrée financière il ya ce souci là
cette question là dans digne ça c'est
peut-être la réalité mais encore une
fois je voudrais revenir sur mon
problème de fond moi ce que je voudrais
c'est qu'on arrive à continuer de
respecter le corps à dire les acheteurs
qui sont dans la salle
je pense que christie mais ni la vente
des enchères comme il mène une vente de
tableaux de livres 2 avec des acheteurs
anonymes n'y a pas d'acheteur anonyme
dans la salle il ya un jeu à faire et
est ce qui ce qui a fait la réputation
des hospices c'était jeu on va pas
revenir en arrière avec le crieur ai dit
mais c'était quand même ça c'est parti
d'un folklore il y avait on acceptait
que les journalistes rang qui a eu deux
trois phénomènes qui ont fait que les
journalistes s'en trouvera un peu floue
et du et si on flou les journalistes ils
ont peu envie de venir moi j'avais lu un
article de burki pour ne pas le citer et
qui m'avait à l'armée c'est à cause de
ça que j'avais entre le pouce et mon
coup de gueule c'était plus sûr un
problème 2-2 fomc de forme singulière
oui mais je pense aussi que les
augmentations de prix aux hospices mais
aussi à la propriété qu'on en compte et
est le fruit de 30 40 ans d'histoire de
la bourgogne au fil du temps évidemment
le vin a quitté cette notion d'aliments
de boissons pour devenir un produit
culturel est évidemment qu aujourd'hui
avec la mondialisation parce que produit
culturel est largement plus valorisé que
lorsqu'il était simplement un aliment je
pense qu'il ya aussi ce phénoménal qui
sert qui a débuté dans les années 70
est ce qu'un risque de surchauffe est ce
que à un moment donné les augmentations
assez régulière de prix on pense
beaucoup aux grands crus par exemple on
peut aboutir à un phénomène
qui va poser souci est est-ce que c'est
non pas le rôle d'une interprofession
d'organiser la réflexion autour du prix
des vins et des produits alors ça sera
un sujet de réflexion effectivement la
latière profession le problème c'est que
on peut pas contrôler ni imposé d'abord
si légales et en plus on a du mal à le
faire et je pense pas qu'on puisse
empêcher des gens qui ont beaucoup de
vin et que les appellations très connus
d'augmenter leurs prix maintenant si on
doit parler d'incidence sur le marché je
pense qu'à un moment donné on pourra
reprocher à l'abdomen ce qu'on a
beaucoup reproché aux bordelais au cours
des dernières années
ça c'est le risque c'est à dire des vins
les plus prestigieux qui s'envolent
totalement voir certains seulement les
vins les plus prestigieux parce que les
vins les plus prestigieux pardon sont
toujours acheté par une clientèle qu'il
l'ait boudera ça c'est le côté
spéculatif c'est le côté j'allais dire
m'as tu vu mais un petit peu c'est le
côté snobisme qui fait qu'on voudra du
musée ni d'humour haché etc etc
par contre sur des appellations moindre
duras quand même il ya quand même des
augmentations qui existe aujourd'hui et
qui à mon avis à un moment donné puisque
des pénalisante même si ça dure pas dans
le temps pendant une période donnée
le temps que les gens acceptent la
légère augmentation ou la très forte
augmentation
facile d'accepter le légère qu'une très
forte il y aura une perte de marchés moi
je le vois quand on va dans les magasins
et puis qu'on dit tiens il ya l'on voit
un vin qui a augmenté parce qu'ils
valent et et le prix est qu'il est passé
à 30% plus cher quand on interroge les
vendeurs disent on entend moins alors
conséquence de ça ou pas d'ailleurs vous
allez nous dire on voit une évolution
dans les ventes des terres après la
vente des vins on a beaucoup parlé ça
fait énormément parler de la vente du
château et les vignes de gevrey
chambertin investisseurs chinois de
macao mais il ya eu en réalité tout un
une suite de transactions assez
importante avec en particulier des gens
spécialisés en luxe françois pinault par
exemple qu'il restait un domaine à
vosne-romanée lvmh qui viendra c'est le
clos des lambrays ça c'est des grosses
ventes
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train d'entrer
dans quelque chose de complètement
nouveau thierry gaudillère en bourgogne
avec on va dire des gens qui font le vin
qui vont de moins en moins posséder la
terre ça devient pour pour certaines
plus en plus difficile évidemment mais
cette évolution des prix ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je regardais le prix moyen
de l'hectare en côte d'or 1 et 2 515
milles euros
il était à 100 97 milles en 1995
donc la hausse s'était aussi fait sur 20
ans donc
alors ça c'est d'une façon générale et
en saône est loin aujourd'hui
les prix sont à 66 mille euros l'hectare
alors qu'ils étaient il ya vingt ans à
47 milles donc oui il ya une hausse du
foncier mais évidemment compare plus
facilement de la transaction qui a eu
sur le plot del hombre que sur une
parcelle de village où de premiers crus
donc mais c'est vrai quand même que se
posent problème pour des domaines
familiaux lac de la capacité à pouvoir
transmettre les les les terres à leurs
enfants et est donc à mettre en place
peut-être des outils fiscaux ou autre
pour permettre ça ça c'est dit on mange
à vide avant de parler des climats vous
vous occupez des climats vous dirigez
aussi un domaine on va dire prestigieux
en côte de beaune c'est quelque chose
qui est sensible ça c'est arrivé
d'investisseurs parler des grands
groupes qui aujourd'hui possède des
châteaux dans le bordelais à l'étranger
commencent à arriver en briguant
beaucoup plus qu'à une époque on m'en
avait parlé dans les années 70 80 et
finalement ça s'était très peu passé à
l'époque ça fasse mal ce que je pense ce
que des tirs étaient d'ailleurs est tout
à fait juste en face d'eux s'est passé
sur 20 ans d'augmentation des prix mais
ça se passait à un moment où il ya toute
une génération qui
qui quitte la bourgogne qui aurait donc
il passe la main et c'est à ce passage
de génération qu'on va voir la douleur
pour les domaines familiaux de
l'augmentation des prix du foncier
c'est pas c'est pas au bon moment x ou y
à la transaction du clos des lambrays
mais c'est quand moi je prendrai ma
retraite ou en équivalent chez d'autres
domaines familiaux de la région de l'est
des côtes de beaune et de nuits qu'on
nous en prendre notre retraite et qu'on
voudra distribuer nos domaines familiaux
à nos enfants
on prendra en pleine face l'augmentation
de la valeur du foncier c'est là où
c'est difficile pour les domaines
familiaux
c'est pas au point à la voix l'instant t
où lvmh je paye un prix ridicule pour le
clos des lambrays sais pas vous dîtes
ridicule parce que très élevé très élevé
le jeu pas dire je ne sais pas ridicule
c'est celle un sens incroyable de faire
un sens incroyable
sarah des conséquences sur la bourgogne
et est-ce que chevalier fera des
conséquences même sur la façon de
fonctionner de la bourgogne qui est en
train de se passer
on sait qu un domaine qui tombe dans
l'escarcelle d'un grand groupe il ya
plusieurs châteaux pas forcément être
dirigée et gérée avec les mêmes
objectifs que nous étions familial ça je
suis moins convaincu parce que je pense
que le dernier réservé aux hommes qu'on
a eus rouge que finalement les gens se
bongo mieux bourguignonne is
ainsi c'est à dire qu'ils appliquent pas
forcément une standard mais generali
augmentation des prix tout de suite
quand même dans les rachats
oui mais mais mais on a déjà parlé de ça
dans les années 90 à une époque où on
disait qu'il y avait pas beaucoup de
transactions dans les vignes il ya plein
de d'institutionnels qui ont acheté des
vignes cette époque par les potes de
mode du luxe ont parlé d'institutionnels
accompagné d'assurances beaucoup de ces
s'est pas vraiment nouveau comme ce
phénomène à mon avis dire qu'il ya en
plus il pas temps de transaction que
c'est en bourgogne
effectivement sur les grandes
appellations et sur les trucs très
prestigieux il y aura toujours
suffisamment de gens des milliardaires
dans le monde y en a de plus en plus des
amateurs de vins de plus en plus je
parlais avec un vendeur de tableaux
avant-hier si quelqu'un qui veut acheter
une ou vraiment à chier ça a été le cas
pour pino de bâtard montrachet
il s'est payé une oeuvre d'art mais ça
reste marginal
à mon avis ça reste marginal temps
maintenant aux problèmes des successions
moi j'ai toujours dit que tu parlais de
thierry tu parlais des des moyens
juridiques y en existe quelqu'un qui
pense à faire ces successions bien avant
c'est à dire qui fait des donations ou
des choses bien avant gère le problème
même si les prix des vignes des vignes
sont chers les prix des mâles sont aussi
donc ça permet de de payer la succession
seulement le problème c'est que bien
souvent tout le monde n'est pas prêt à
donner à passer la main donc après on se
retrouve devant le fait accompli
il ya une autre situation dont on parle
moins sept ces dernières années la
création très souvent pour augmenter la
surface de vignes ou pour contourner
certaines difficultés de groupements
fonciers viticoles avec des
investisseurs ça peut être un ou deux
investisseurs ça peut être souvent des
groupes d'investisseurs
certaines personnes disent que c'est une
bombe à retardement en réalité parce que
pour l'instant tout va bien tout le
monde est content d'avoir des gens qui
vous permettent d'avoir plus de vie mais
que quand on va arriver à une génération
et tu auras des transmissions qui aura
des reventes
il ya toute une partie du foncier
bourguignons qui aura était déjà parti
en petits morceaux
est ce que c'est vrai ça va je pense
qu'il ya une part de vérité là-dedans
alors ce que je voulais dire aussi c'est
bien souvent les gens qui critiquent le
fait qu' il ya des investisseurs
étrangers qui viennent sont les premiers
en chercher donc c'est le shaq de chien
qui se mord la queue ou le chat qui se
mord la queue sait plus comment on dit
mais c'est un peu ça donc moi j'ai
l'exemple par exemple de quelqu'un
qu'ils aient jamais c'est pas normal que
limite survendu à quelqu'un qui joue il
a vendu une vigne puis c'était
investisseurs qui l'ont acheté
il n'a pas cherché d'où venait l'argent
donc il faut qu'on soit il faut qu'on
soit raisonnable il faut il faut pas
seulement dire c'est pas normal et et
faire le contraire de ce qu'on entend
dire c'est vrai que tout type de domaine
aujourd'hui cherche des investisseurs
par dgf à des petits domaines comme des
domaines aussi très prestigieux parce
que le prix du foncier affaire fait que
chacun peut plus investir parce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est peut-être
parce que un viticulteur est aussi
amateur d'oeuvre d'art
l'avenir c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de viticulteurs qui préfèrent acheter
des appellations prestigieuses
plutôt que d'acheter des petites
appellations qui finalement sont
toujours à un coût raisonnable est là et
effectivement la première chose qui
vient à l'esprit d'un viticulteur céda
laissez moi j'ai pas assez d'argent pour
par contre je connais des gens quand
dont ils vont l'acheter pour moi et il y
en existe des gens qui achètent
j'ai l'exemple de discuter avec
quelqu'un des hospices il avait perdu un
acheteur qui avait acheté pour cent
cinquante mille euros de vins et donc
ils lui ont recontacté yves n'est pas
enlever le vin est cette personne là se
souvenait plus qu'il avait acheté pour
cent cinquante mille euros de vins bien
vite c'est dire que aujourd'hui c'est
comme une oeuvre d'art il avait oublié
de deuxième chapitre de notre émission
et du coupé je voudrais juste dire un
truc finalement l'avantagé d'être ya un
avantage quand j'aime assad d'avoir des
prix qui vont bien foncier ça veut dire
que la bourgogne est connu reconnu et
reconnu mondialement
on va dire qu'à une certaine époque
l'avenir on aurait bien aimé être dans
cette situation je relis le prix des
terres au prix du vin dans la bouteille
alors oui il ya des vins qui deviennent
inaccessibles pour nous parce que ça
devient un village de côte de nuits à 50
euros
bon oui c'est cher mais je pense qu'en
bourgogne
il ya toujours des jolis vins des bovins
accessible moi j'ai prendre le en
mâconnais a viré clessé l'autre jour
chez un caviste joyent est un vin que je
connais d'un domaine qui fait des
superbes choses
kéké à 12 euros voilà le message le
message est passé pour ceux qui nous
regardent le grand dossier de l'année un
des grands dossiers
guillaume d'angerville ça va être
effectivement les climats sa dossier de
longue main comme on disait dans le
temps qui dure depuis qui dure depuis
longtemps
est ce que c'est la dernière ligne
droite
est ce que vous êtes presque au bout est
ce que à la fin de l'année 2015 la
bourgogne au patrimoine mondial écoutez
je peux pas faire un pronostique aussi
clair que celui là bien entendu mais ce
que je peux vous dire quand même en deux
mots c'est comme vous le dites c'est un
très très vieux dossier puisque aubert
de villaine à qui il faut rendre ici
hommage à démarrer cette grande aventure
il ya maintenant 8 ans et que depuis
janvier 2014
nous sommes effectivement cantina
officielle de la france pour rejoindre
la liste du patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco et déjà être candidat officiel
de la france c'est déjà une énorme et à
part il faut se rendre compte que pour
devenir candidat officiel de la france
il faut avoir convaincu le comité
national des biens français que notre
dossier valait la peine nous sommes
présentés par la france et nous sommes
devenus depuis janvier 2014
le dossier de la france n'ont pas le
dossier de la bourgogne on est on est le
dossier de la france est notre pays qui
nous déclare candidat et donc depuis ce
moment-là l'unesco a effectivement
confirmé que notre dossier était complet
conforme ap câble vous avez eu des
inspecteurs à l'automne et nous avons
reçu la visite d'un inspecteur à
l'automne qui est
c'était bien et pas bien à la fois il
est arrivé fin septembre c'est à dire
moi j'étais en dedans mais vinification
on était tous un petit peu à la cuverie
et en même temps il fallait s'occuper
d'eux de montrer à ce monsieur qui était
quelqu'un de très compétent à c'est un
spécialiste italien des paysages
notamment paysage naturel donc quelqu'un
de très compétent mais il fallait le
promener il fallait s'occuper de lui
pendant une semaine entière et à la
suite de cette visite qui sait je pense
bien passé en plus dans des conditions
climatiques agréable donc la bourgogne
était sous son meilleur visage
nous avons eu nous avons entamé une
période qu'on peut appeler questions
réponses un petit peu avec l'unesco avec
avec les experts du panel de l'unesco
qui étudie notre dossier et cette
période n'est pas complètement terminée
avant dire on a eu une première série de
questions avant avant la fin de l'année
au mois de novembre
et puis dans là une deuxième à laquelle
nous devons répondre là dans les
semaines qui viennent
et nous prenons ces questions de manière
positive parce qu'elles sont des
questions tout à fait légitimes
intéressante bien posée et qui montre
bien que l'unesco a étudié le dossier de
manière intéressante et de manière
constructive et donc nous sommes nous
sommes confiants que nous avons une
bonne réponse pour cela mais néanmoins
après il ya la décision du panel d
experts qui est quand même un petit peu
une boîte noire pas exactement savoir
comment tout ça se passe et puis enfin
au mois de juillet il y aura le vote
officiel des 21 pays membres de l'unesco
qui sont également membres du comité du
patrimoine mondial
et c'est le vote de ces 21 pays qui
déterminera finalement syllabes 9,4
cette année ou si pour des raisons
techniques il faut encore attendre
faudra attendre encore un an je peux le
chevalier c'est une attente
est ce que c'est une attente forte du
monde viticole et vous vous doutez de
deux du mauvais esprit que je mets dans
cette question et que c'est pas plus un
dossier des politiques du monde du
tourisme que du monde des minéraux en
réalité je pense que je pense pas parce
que au départ c'est quand même le
j'aurais tendance à dire c'est comme une
monde viticole cas relancer le dossier
donc à partir de ce moment là
effectivement il ya toujours comme dans
toutes les grandes de cause il ya
toujours des gens qui sont contre au
départ mais qui si jamais ça arrive vont
dire vont être les premiers à avoir une
fierté extraordinaire de se retrouver
dans le patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
donc je considère aujourd'hui que c'est
devenu une attente pour la plupart des
gens en bourgogne
même si encore j'ai encore et de 30
personnes qui vont avoir des réticences
parce que ça va nous a posés dit oui
voilà c'est ça c'est ça qu'on entend
c'est mais en même temps nos vingt
secondes déjà bien qu'est-ce qu'on va
s'embêter à se rajouter des règles alors
qu'à sayat nova l'objet et wc pas
l'objet d'augmenter le postiche de la
bourgogne qui n'a pas besoin de ça pour
la voir le petit viticole de la
bourgogne il existe déjà
non c'est je pense qu'hier on a parlé un
tout petit peu avant le début de
l'émission avec tirer je pense qu'il ya
un élément extrêmement extrêmement
important de cette candidature et qui ne
dépend à vrai dire pas du résultat
évidemment on attend avec impatience
d'être inscrits mais le simple fait que
nous ayons lancé cette candidature il ya
en a fait prendre conscience à l'état de
gens de l'unique de l'aspect unique de
notre région
du côté totalement incroyablement
spéciale de la viticulture bourguignonne
de la viticulture de terroir de cette
manière de lier le vin produit au lieu
sur lequel il est produit de manière
tellement tellement tellement spécifique
est tellement fine et de ce point de vue
là c était révélateur pour les tas de
gens et je pense que ça contribue à
fédérer les gens autour de ce dossier de
comprendre tout d'un coup grâce à cette
candidature
la richesse de notre région il c'est
vrai que l'objet du classement c'est un
patrimoine qui vit vives ont classé les
pyramides
bon voilà elles sont là on est dans ce
cas mais sa boucherie et c'est vrai que
le fait que ça soit un patrimoine vivant
au hockey au centre duquel il ya des
villes des villages des gens qui
travaillent qui circulent tous les jours
ça c'est c'est pas banal et ça crée des
inquiétudes
inévitablement mais je pense pas que ce
soit le classement qu'il va changer les
choses
on le voit le comment la côte
méridionale des bonnes c'est à dire le
sud de beaune a été classé au début des
années 90 au titre d'aidé des sites
remarquables sapera figer le dynamisme
de cette partie là dedans je vais
revenir le new york times qui donne
chaque année 1 et 52 endroit qu'il faut
visiter dans le monde a classé la
bourgogne 15e cette année et entre
autres alors il est question des
vignerons il est question d hôtel il est
question de la candidature des climats à
l'unesco
est ce que c'est un signe positif
écoutez je vais je vais vous surprendre
mais je pense que je pense que aux états
unis il ya il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui sont extrêmement conscient de
l'aspect unique de la bourgogne et qui
sont très amoureux de la bourgogne et
moi personnellement ce je suis très
heureux évidemment qu'on soit dans ses
52 destinations possibles et je suis
très heureux qu'ils aient une référence
spécifique au climat mais je peux pas
dire que je sois complètement étonné
parce que les états unis sont depuis
je suis sûr que tu seras d'accord et ce
depuis toujours des grands amateurs de
la bourgogne des grandes amateurs de
notre région et ils le font a créé
spéciaux revient au sujet des
investisseurs ces investisseurs fameux
dont on parlait à l'instant il y en a
beaucoup qui viennent des états unis et
ils le font d'une certaine manière un
peu comme une oeuvre d'art aussi c'est
quelque chose pour eux c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire d'être
propriétaire de quelques ouvrés de alors
j au margrave il est situé à venait un
mot un petit peu moins consensuel claude
chevalier
on sait que dijon fait partie du réseau
des sites et de la gastronomie
on sait qu'il va y avoir des lieux
obligatoire pour les climats de
bourgogne et on a appris que ben on crée
aussi une cité du vin et que
l'interprofession était derrière ça ce
que ça fait pas beaucoup d'endroits
finalement il ya trois ans durant parce
qu'on va quand même rappeler que beaune
a été recalé dans les cités de la
gastronomie etc la cité du vin est
arrivé juste après la cité du vin dans
la réalité ici même si la cité de la
gastronomie avance assez vite à dijon et
même si l on veut donner je trouvais
qu'elle n'avançait plus mais là il est
reparti on a on n'a jamais dire à des
accords on se rend compte régulièrement
avec la cité de la gastronomie pour
faire en sorte que la cité du vin soit
quelque chose qui soit légèrement
différent et qui soit complètement
d'accord vous n'êtes pas en concurrence
n'est pas une pipe et la gastronomie 10
on aurait on aurait pu penser à un
moment donné quand vous avez raison
politique
voilà on se souvient dans la campagne
des municipales qu'en 7ème sauf que ça
c'est fini aujourd'hui on est réellement
dans la construction
je parle pour bonne cité divin qui sera
une base pour des portes d'entrée qui
vont se trouvaient également dans
d'autres départements tels que la côte
d'or et l'yonne
mais on est dans une logique avec la
cité de la gastronomie qui fera que ça
fera un tout et que le touriste qui
viendra en bourgogne visiter la cité de
la gastronomie pourra visiter la cité
des vins ça te portera peut-être un
autre nom dans le futur parce que je
pense pas que ce soit le meilleur mais
il ya une réelle complémentarité qui qui
qui existent et qui ont l'air en très
bons rapports avec tout le monde
et le projet avance également ravi il va
falloir faire marcher pour ça avait bien
sûr mais ça a énormément de sens c'est
il faut il faut pas je pense qu'il faut
pas chercher des difficultés là il y en
a vraiment pas je crois qu'il ya une
complémentarité évidente entre entre ces
deux institutions à venir l'une plus
avancée que l'autre mais plus du point
de vue des climats il est évident qu'on
aura besoin d'un lieu qui nous permettra
aux touristes qui arrivent de se diriger
vers les climats et moi j'y pense
vraiment comme étant une porte d'entrée
un sas vers la découverte des climats
sur le terrain 1 donc c'est pas un
endroit où type musée fermé il y aura
évidemment des tas d'activités dans ceux
à l'intérieur de cette cité des vins
mais ce sera surtout l'occasion pour le
touriste de comprendre où il doit aller
pour comprendre les climats et se
promener un peu dans le dans ses fameux
climat on avance un petit peu et il nous
reste quatre minutes pendant la première
phase de cette émission ça passe très
vite pour parler d'un autre dossier
d'actualité qui fait qu'on a parlé de la
bourgogne ça a été qu'on appelle à père
gilles bouleau du nom de ce viticulteur
qui n'a pas accepté les traitements
préventifs sur la flavescence dorée sur
son insecte la cicadelle qui donne cette
maladie et il ya eu un glissement très
vite dans cette affaire claude chevalier
où finalement on est passé de quelqu'un
qui refusaient les traitements
préventifs pour une maladie particulière
à une bulle médiatique dans laquelle on
parlait du refus des traitements et des
produits phytosanitaires en général est
ce que vous me confirmer que ça a été
très mal vécue par une grande partie du
monde viticole ce moment là je pense que
c'est le côté médiatique était mal vécu
c'est c'est la façon dont ça s'est passé
dans la réalité des fêtes
moi je le dis la bourbonne depuis plus
de 10 ans a avancé de manière la vitesse
grand v dans la lutte raisonnée et vers
le bio moi je ne sais pas je connais pas
les chiffres actuels mais je sais qu'il
ya 4 5 ans c'était certainement une
région viticole où il y avait le plus
grand pourcentage de visiteurs bio la
différence entre viticulteurs d'il ya
quinze ans en arrière et un viticulteur
aujourd'hui c'est que plus personne n'a
envie pollué par contre on a tous besoin
de vivre ça veut dire qu'on a quand même
besoin de protéger notre vignoble pour
qu'ils puissent continuer de produire
c'est quand même la base du métier
s'il ya plus de vignes on produira plus
de 20
donc ça mais en plus ça va certainement
pas arranger beaucoup de gens à travers
le monde s'il y avait plus de 20 de
bourgogne mais il faut rester
pragmatique il faut pas être extrémiste
10 dans un côté ni dans un style a pas
joué un rôle de lanceur d alerte et
mandy boulot parce que finalement est ce
qu'il n'ya pas eu après ça un certain
nombre de villages qui sont quand même
mis à faire des choses plus fines dans
la recherche de cette maladie que un
certain nombre de traitements
systématiques qui ont eu lieu en
particulier on va le dire dans le sud de
la bourgogne dans le mâconnais ou au
départ on a vraiment traité de façon
systématique est ce que c'est vrai ça
alors c'est justement ça c'est un sujet
ça mais ça m'a un peu agacé voire
beaucoup à guérir
gilles bouleau s'est fait passer pour le
promoteur d'une d'une campagne de lutte
contre la flavescence dorée beaucoup
plus soft
la réalité c'est que la première année
la toute première année où il était
décidé de faire des traitements contre
la cicadelle ces traitements été
raisonné sa politique du systématique
sur les trois départements tels qu'il a
bien voulu entendre
l'yonne n'a pas traité du tout parce
qu'il n'y avait aucun risque de maladies
la saône-et-loire à traiter beaucoup
parce qu'il y avait 20 hectares qui
étaient en train de s'arracher
ce cadeau ni le résultat quand même que
l'année d'après il ya eu zéro die avoir
0,2 hectares à arracher alors qu'on
s'attendait à voir 40 hectares donc là
on allait sur la prévention et la
première année avant même que les
traitements ou dans le même temps que
les traitements
il ya déjà trois mille viticulteurs qui
sont baladés dans les vignes pour
repérer les choses donc on n'a pas
attendu que manuel giboulot donne des
leçons à tout le monde fasse semblant de
donner des leçons pour prendre des
mesures qui allaient contre le fait
qu'on puisse ne plus mettre qu'elle est
plutôt qui de calais dans le vert le
fait qu'on puisse ne plus traiter avec
des insecticides sauf dans des cas
extrêmes où il y avait toujours une
nécessité
je peux dire à brest minutes je pense
que la campagne 2014 a déjà été un
énorme projet par projet par la pop par
rapport à la campagne 2013 et moi de mon
point de vue je suis pas fanatique nom +
dvd des traitements lourds préventif
et très extensif mais je pense que la
solution elle est dans la prospection
elle est dans l'analyse par les
vignerons de leur vignoble régulièrement
dans des dans des campagnes de
prospection extrêmement extrêmement
discipliné qu'on doit continuer à faire
pour éviter la maladie
c'est ça merci à tous les trois pour
cette première partie d'émission il ya
encore un certain nombre d'autres thèmes
dont on va parler parlera de la grêle et
vous êtes bien placé pour le savoir du
mozart vite parce qu'elle a touché
fortement volnay on parlera aussi du
beaujolais pas ce qu'il se passe des
choses en beaujolais pas très loin la
bourgogne on dirait un petit mot aussi
de la saint vincent tournante ce qui se
passe ce week-end dans deux villages
bourguignon est d'ailleurs la saint
vincent tournante il en est question
quelques instants dans le flash de midi
qui va commencer dans une poignée de
secondes on se retrouve nous juste après
pour la deuxième partie de la voie libre
à tout de suite